In addition to motivation for belonging, we also see as humans we have a
motivation to excel, which is incredibly beneficial to the workplace. This is
achievement motivation. Achievement motivation is a desire to do things well
and to overcome obstacles. In general, when we succeed at something that's very
difficult, we find it more meaningful. Then if we were to succeed at something
that was easy, because if we succeed at something that's easy, then it doesn't
really tell us much about our abilities. For example, you're most likely to
derive more meaning from successfully finishing a half-marathon than you would
feel for just walking a mile. Let's move on to talk about achievement in
regards to motivation in the workplace. If you recall from lesson one when we
discussed a different sub field of psychology, this is where the sub field of
Industrial and Organizational psychology comes into play. I/o psychology
studies motivation and behavior in the workplace. And yes as you can imagine
employers want to know what motivates their employees.